tom hiddleston and zaway ashton are
engaged
it's really exciting et has learned that
the former co-stars are tying the knot
after sparking engagement rumors while
attending the 2022 baftas
what caused the speculation zaway
rocking a ring on that finger
match made in heaven you know
but at first it seemed like she may have
been shy to show it off posing on the
red carpet in her stunning pink gown
with her hands subtly positioned off to
the side
but later in the night the sparkler was
on full display in this pic with tom and
british tv personality aj odudu
so where did tom and zaway's love story
begin well the two met on the set of the
2019 play betrayal and though tom and
zaway didn't confirm their relationship
at the time some reports claim they
started dating after working together on
the production jump to september 2021
and the couple was spotted packing on
the pda in spain and later that month
tom and zaway walked their first red
carpet together at the tony awards
yeah it's a dream
and it looks like there's a possibility
for tom and zowie to work together again
the english actress is joining the
marvel cinematic universe in the
upcoming captain marvel sequel the
marvels playing a villain and of course
tom is a vet in the mcu playing loki in
the thor and avengers films and most
recently in the disney plus series
spin-off titled what else loki it's been
a source of constant surprise and
delight that i've played this character
for so long i i had no idea when i
auditioned that i would be
sat here 10 years down the road and and
still doing it loki is so complex so
every time i come back to play him i'm
like right let's have a look at this bit
you know he's like got all these little
interesting facets
and aspects to him
um
i feel quite lucky that i'm
able to just keep digging i suppose yeah
it's uh it's been an amazing ride
so while we keep our fingers crossed for
that marvel crossover
we'll just be here sending big congrats
to the happy couple
[Music]
you